[Music]
my congresswoman Alexandria Casa Cortez
now accusing Kelly and Conway of
questioning her faith following a
twitter exchange over the
congresswoman's alleged silence in the
immediate aftermath of the Srilanka
attacks here's now with reaction
counselor to the president Kelly income
weigh your net you're never shy about
responding which I like because when I
was on social media I did the same thing
a lot maybe more than I should have even
well Sean I usually leave her alone I'm
not as prolific a tweeter as she is in
some other people I choose to live my
life offline I usually leave Alexandria
Casa Cortez and some of these other
freshmen like Ilhan Omar and to leave
alone because basically when they speak
it's a gift but two conservatives in to
the Republican Party when she holds
forth about we can't have any more gas
we can't have any more cows we can't
have any more gas coming from cows she
says the world is gonna end in the next
12 years doesn't seem to understand the
way tax incentives work she got rid of
Amazon and the 25,000 jobs it was going
to bring to New York and and then said
well we can't give away three billion
dollars to them meaning she really
didn't understand the way the tax
incentives work she said that the
unemployment rate is so low because
people have two jobs I mean all of this
is which is crazy and she's being
brushed back by none other than the
speaker Pelosi saying hey this class of
water can win in those safe Liberal
Democratic districts and what are their
just five of them really brushing back
some of these progressive freshmen
because Pelosi of course is under
enormous pressure to actually produced
and perform and has a lot of more
centrist moderate members who came to
Washington try to get things done but I
really had a caller out here because I'm
on television shows and I'm asked
constantly why didn't Donald Trump say
this why did you use that word where's
the semicolon in his tweet where I
believe it should be and I said hey why
does anybody ask alexandria Ocasio
cortez who you give a hero's welcome to
all you fangirls ever bother to ask her
why she's been completely silent on the
massacre against sri lankans on easter
sunday and i only ask that because i had
noticed that she had tweeted many times
about the killings of the mosque
and she had tweeted about other things
and I was on the same show condemning
violence against people of all faiths I
said specifically by name the mosque in
New Zealand the Emanuel AME Church in
Charleston South Carolina the Christians
in southern Springs Texas this tree of
life synagogue in Pittsburgh the
synagogue in Poway California and on and
on it went so we and my boss the
president I states and me and others we
are condemning attacks on people of all
faiths people should feel safe at all
times but particularly when you're in
your place of worship regardless of your
faith so I'm not questioning her faith
or anyone elses but why was she silent
so she said on Twitter I said it on TV
showing a different number she said on
Twitter hey I was away from tech I was
visiting my grandmother for Easter I
think that's wonderful but the very next
day is they were still picking through
the rubble in Srilanka looking for
survivors or the deceased she had time
to tweet about her neck and flicks
documentary about her and so I think
that we all choose what we weigh in on
away on I'm the first to say people are
not compelled to weigh in on everything
but those things about her faith it's
about her selectivity you know look
problem is a new green deal it's the
fact that there's over a hundred
Democrats in the House and Senate and
these presidential candidates are
supported and everything's gonna be free
and get rid of cows and airplanes and
the combustion engine oil and gas it's
insane
but the problem is they play to win
innate fear of people we have less than
a minute and the fear is Oh will we
promise every worry in your life is gone
and I'm like remember keep your doctor
plan and pay less they never fulfill
that promise that's the scary part I
think people are too smart for that by
the way speaking of the green new deal
she got a lot of again fanfare and
hero's welcome for that and then when it
went to the actual vote in the United
States Senate not a single Democrat
voted for it they were so cowardly they
voted present including those who are
running for president said we must have
a greener deal this is the future yay
and then they didn't have the guts to
even give an affirmative vote to it so a
lot of these ideas
great there are sugar high empty
calories free this for that Americans
are too smart for that when they hear
that you're going to have free housing
free college free health care they know
they're going to be the ones paying the
bill someway somehow we don't want to
take a government takeover in medicine
we don't want to up their private
insurance system and Medicare for all
those choices for not and so on and
always great to see you and thanks for
you doing